so good afternoon
for introduction
was a crazy day I had issues with
internet connection so my PDF version
might not be the best fit but it works
and there are slides it's cool
and moreover actually have you ever had
a feeling that you're attending a
conference you think that you have a day
off okay no conference not no work today
of the duty and you're slack or chat or
mail is pinging you hey Robert your
project is on fire burn help us hell no
actually it was me 15 minutes ago 15
minutes ago betwee before this
presentation I got a slack message that
there is a project burn actually my
project management thought I am an
attendee of the conference not a speaker
then god
but actually I okay I saw your used
right ru refused I said to her that okay
I prefer to show my presentation I've
been working on not fixing bugs so I'm
not sure if I'm going back to my work on
Monday and yeah in case I got a question
for you are there any recruiters done
because of yes I will be in touch on
Monday since Monday actually yeah but
seriously I'm kidding I don't want to
lose my job I'm not sure if they won't
be back on Monday
but actually if yes is okay my real
question was honestly really is there
anybody of you who was involved in
machine learning engineers or deep lair
no data engineers recruitment somebody
who was asking technical questions to
candidates or something yeah okay great
thanks because if yes are you sure okay
if yes I'm wondering if your feelings
about this recruitment is the same as
mine because in the last two months I
was supposed to help in data engineering
recruitment and in my company actually
it was a rule that data engineers are
relatively close to much learning
engineers so my first question to
candidates was do you know how much
learning team handles data versioning
storage etc second question was how do
you handle experiments and the answers
were rather not satisfying to me
actually because the most common answer
for this question is okay I heard about
good practices but actually it's not
related to mine project because it's not
standard it's not typical oh please okay
I have to stand right back here okay so
yeah actually nobody everybody knows
about the good practices in machine
learning flows about the storage of data
and the handling experiments but as I
said so nobody uses that and that's bad
let's change it let's change it with the
presentation in here welcome my name is
my name is Robert kosnovski
I work in that Google company and
welcome on board okay so let's go to the
next slide in the end okay so I started
discovering the topic yeah last year and
I found a good quote from the guy from
Google not a random person from Google
technical lead on tensorflow so it's a
quote it's so bad it sometimes feels
like stepping back in time to when we
coded without source control sounds
terrible so of course I keep attention
to DevOps two flows and the consistency
of development because previously I've
been a back-end developer web developer
for five years so things like DevOps
continuously integration and etc was
necessary for us I went to mush learning
because it was a great field to
adventure and then I saw ok you don't
have such specific concepts such
specific flows
why not and then I went to Google Trends
and I typed out ml ops machine learning
operations so it is typical to related
to DevOps but rather to mushroom in
machine learning field and what can I
see nowadays the trend is high okay and
we can see actually because the one of
the keynotes today was sort of relevant
to Marshall learning flow and the second
presentation in room one is also about
some machine learning flows and good
practices but in April it was like 25
percents so not everybody was thinking
about this I am afraid of thinking what
was two years ago that's why we have to
think about this okay so let's think
about let's talk about the standard
project we got in for example back into
web development so we have these five
steps like planning this is a this is an
idea then this is analysis so we have to
think how to change ideas into tasks and
then into code then we have to design so
let's imagine that we have back and down
but we haven't front and discussed yet
and then implementation so the
developers can have fun a bit and then
maintenance so if we deploy the first
version we can think what should be
fixed what should be improved and the
circles goes around okay but we have
machine learning so it is called in some
places software development 2.0 so
instant that way we have algorithm the
developers write code and they have some
data from databases at most and they
have output as a front-end and work in
back-end in machine learning we don't
have algorithm per se in strict way we
have outputs we have data and we want to
that remind algorithm so we have to go
go with another flow so key differences
between the standard flow in back-end
development for example and Marshall
learning the
and from my point of view they are
terrific three things first of all first
of all data in the backend development
we have data like for example five
gigabytes of data of users would be
quite large it's not a big data yet of
course because in machine learning we
know a lot cases that data are terabytes
there are for example Kara's challenges
with video processing from Google it was
really difficult challenge on Google
just because the data volume is so big
that we cannot handle that on our local
machines so we have to do something so
data is first secondly experiments so we
are talking about that like we do in
machine learning so we are creating
models we are tree we are preparing
experiments we are making training test
validation all that stuff and our model
file is being done okay but of course
there is it's no one experiment it's a
bunch of experiments with different
parameters who the hell would not
mistake if somebody would manage that in
manual way so we have to somehow
maintain the experiments we get and then
we have to deploy that because for
example in my first machine learning
project two commercial projects I was so
happy that I produced a file with model
for machine learning model but what else
for a client it was nothing
okay they he said to me ok you have a
model great job but I actually don't
know what to do with that please deploy
and if deployment is a task for one
person and for one project one time it's
not a problem ok you can copy the model
into for example iOS or Android code
application and you have everything
working but what if I have 50 iterations
we have 15 models and we have to deploy
it somehow we can we should think about
this how to do it in an effective way
yeah so let's go in to update that
circle of mush and learning project not
back-end project so we have some
steps we have the engineer get
engineering at first so we have to take
data from clients understand them think
how to format the data into our format -
for example CSV files some databases -
python depends on the size and depends
of the format of data we have to do some
data processing then data insights maybe
we need some data enrichment maybe the
amount of data from client is not enough
so we have to do something with that if
we got the data topic closed we can go
into pipeline pipeline we have to do
something in Python to convert the code
from the model to the deployment and -
if we have pipeline we have first
baseline model which is the first model
we got the first results first metrics
we are happy but it's not the end
actually it's just a start of our
journey and then if we have baseline
model we have to deploy it so we can try
the baseline model on real case on real
apps for example for beta testers and
then we have model motive monitoring so
we can see if our model is a final one
or should we once again go around with
this circle so yeah we have code we have
data we have training testing and
building process with deployment at the
end so I collected all this free into ml
operations process so we have to handle
all those elements into specific
positions and we have to use the
specific tools to make it in an
effective way
first of all I would like to talk about
data there are some challenges in data
first of all its versioning so let's
imagine I am the only one project in
machine learning product I'm the only
one developer in the project so it's
okay I remember actually what kind of
data I got what kind of versions of data
I got but if I have a team of 10 people
as a problem for us because not
everybody can see notice any changes in
data and
changes in datasets are quite common
because maybe client have some new data
for us maybe we have some data
indication and we have we added new data
bunches from other sources to our
previous sauce and make our model more
rich so yeah subsets of data set into
Train test and validation it's also a
case where we should handle the data
properly and using only for example
local machine is not enough thirdly
integrity of data among among all
developers I have already covered this
topic and easy access from for for
Python pipeline code actually I am
working in Python and pandas and other
other frameworks that's why I want to
have a good easy and maintainable access
to make data as a read data to Python
and sometimes write back pay a data from
Python to some files so I wanted to
introduce you the first tool which is
killed killed is a simple of wrapper or
or a WSS free which provides a function
of data versioning tool and I don't know
how many of you knows DBC data version
control tool if yes it's something it
has some commons and differences I
didn't choose DBC as the topic of the of
this of this talk I focused on killed so
killed data versioning wrapper or of AWS
as free and great for me API for Python
ok so cute does data insights the inter
engineering is around the data because
it's a source of data we load into
Python and then it is of course used in
baseline model creation because within
the model creation we use data to train
the model ok so now some examples of
using kilt so you can create a account
killed as you can see on the left top on
the left stop panel it is used as free
buckets so we have to have some as free
bucket and then guilt does some data
versioning for us so it is possible to
have some meta data it is possible to
have several revisions of the same file
so it is quite similar to get for data
it's quite similar for the approach of
DBC in data but actually it's not get
related as much as DBC it's rather
cloud-based tool as a wrapper for as
free so in this case I just explored one
CSV file as my dataset and of course I
can have an example I can I can have a
preview and some metadata with the
shapes realized data size and other
informations we can have also so the
previous view was about the files view
this is about the packages view because
kilt is managing data in packages so we
can see that we have Collins project
this is a project from net guru and we
have a folder a package called
classifier and we have two revisions so
if I make a model I can use the data in
first revision and then if I add
additional data I can simply switch the
digest of the second provision and
immediately use the new data new bunch
of data into the training model okay
about a table yes I actually set a lot
you can visit open dot killed datacom to
see a lot of examples a lots of open
buckets for us and you can see how
killed helps in machine learning
projects in case of data okay so now a
couple of screenshots about loading data
so killed knows that we have data in s3
bucket and it's not a git itself because
we can have
different approaches to handling data we
can fetch the whole data set into the
local machine if we are doing something
locally and it would be one command we
can also fetch him a single files
sometimes we don't need the whole data
set
locally sometimes we want to revise only
the one file so this is the fetch
function from kilt and as you can see
cute is a simple Python package so we
can create an instance we can sign in to
the bucket we we have access to and then
fetch do some files to the local disk
then cute in version two in the previous
version had a really nice syntax because
our data set it was possible to import
data sets as simple Python packages so
guilt free is a package name like the
library name data then Alex II is a
account name and then how that is a
number name of the package and within
the return we have a local package this
is the dictionary so we can achieve the
keys and go for the directories into
specific files okay and if we want to
have the way to in fetch all the data
set we can use guilt free dot package
don't install we can specify top hash so
we I can use the first revision and
after a week I can simply immediately
change into the second revision the
similar is with the Browse method but it
doesn't install the package itself to
the local machine if it's already
present there okay and also as we can
see we can manage our package as a
Python dict simply so we can step
between folders and achieve the files as
you can see in the second line we have
how the data Atlantic storms dot CSV
and we have something called package
entry it's not a content of the file yet
but we can open that with the for
example file that open no open file but
also we can have use the des realized
method and then afterwards we can return
the content of the file so there are
many strategies of handling data in
killed so use whatever you want we can
also setting and uploading packages so
okay I have some source data
I wanted to load it into Python but
maybe after some processing I want to
for example send back the validation set
I created to Train set some subsets
okay so we've in quilt free dot package
dot methods we can set meta dates of the
files we got in package and we can
specify the package into quilt and
within killed push we can load we can
save the data to s free back at him so
it's quite handy for me I guess yes this
is a push and then we can list packages
it so this is quite a synchro between
the packages in s free and our local
ones if we need them okay of also killed
has some killed has some support for
metadata metadata so we can specify the
outer of the file we can specify the
purpose of the file if we got some for
example images we can have the metadata
what kind of resources on the image if
we have audio files which are also
included into killed support we can have
an information about what was the date
of the creation of the file audio data
or what kind of voices inside so also
metadata is quite useful and quilt vs
DBC as we can see DBC works like get
like get killed not necessarily but
actually I see that DBC toe tends to
work like github
we cannot share projects data between
projects itself within codes is not a
problem we can go into a second project
Python code we can make authorization to
killed and we can browse and download
data sources so it's quite handy and
example we have a application made in
that guru which is called lines do you
know shall some application for music
you hear the music but you don't know
the name so you turn on Shazam and it
tells you what kind of song is that it
is forecast so you see the car on the
street we are not sure what kind of car
is that you use the phone and within the
image recognition it is possible to
specify the model of the car and other
informations and within Collins we used
killed as the data sources as the data
versioning so we can see the example
that we have specified some folders with
different types of images and we have
lots of different sources of data so it
was helpful for us to have killed
because different revisions told us when
the data was achieved we had problems
with the baseline model it was really
poor so we decided to make to go to the
city town make a lot of photos of cars
and annotated them by by ourselves
that's why I killed versioning and
revisions and metadata helped us a lot
and another example you can see that
skilled show is able to show images also
okay next topic experiments data is not
only the one concern experiments so we
have this experiments we had we have to
handle hyper parameters or experiments
let's imagine that we have clustering so
we we can have some parameters like the
algorithm of clustering number of
clusters other parameters if we want to
schedule 100 clusterings experiments we
have to somehow handle what kind of her
hyper parameters were stored in one
experiment what was the result what kind
of metric we wanted to find and how it
goes with the error or a success yeah
and also infrastructure if I want to
provide 1,000 experiments I won't do
that on my local machine
I won't schedule any jobs on SSH a
remote machine
I want to something better for that and
that's why I want to show you the second
tool which is poly axon poly axon is
rapper of kubernetes not as free now
experiments kubernetes so we work with
Molly axon to schedule and maintain
experiments so as you probably know
creeper Nettie's is something a bit
better than docker it has some ports
which are sets of containers we are
using in that guru poly action like this
so we have a project I am creating a jam
file with some rules I want to specify a
thousand of experiments with different
hyper parameters and okay I save a jam
file I send it to my github repository
and I run Poli action and I tell to him
ok run this one thousand experiments so
poly excellent connects to kubernetes
kubernetes owns the infrastructure of
how its goes and of the bellow of and
doorbell yeah the lowest level is Google
Cloud processing so yeah in that guru we
use Google Cloud processing machines it
starts it creates a docker container it
has some inside data it does what it
should be so some train prediction it
returns some metrics and it turned off
and of course could be net kubernetes
maintains all this Google Cloud
processing machines ok and so poly
external flow is rather a creation of
baseline model model deployment and
model monitoring I would say of course
it is also visible in pipeline creation
we can have a schema that there is a
poly X and inside we have kubernetes
outside as the below level of the flow
we send jobs we fetch life metrics we
fetch the final model file so it's okay
for us as a data science team and
insights of course in this slide is this
amazing amazing computation resources
but actually we use Google Cloud
processing for now and polyak so this is
a screenshot of actually a single
experiment group so we can have this
jump file and I specify experiment group
about how many of experiments I would
like to fetch at all at once and if it's
a clustering I want to try clustering
with some sets of parameters another
experiment with another sets of
parameters and etc and this poly action
view web panel handles that all within
this view we can see I had 18
experiments and all of these were
successed
okay this is a view of single
experiments so we can see declarations
so hyper parameters or simple column
parameters of the experiment so I was
doing clustering I used key modes
algorithm with with the decomposition of
view map I used metric Hamming I used 50
clusters and this is the simple single
experiment okay so we have a poly axon
CLI if I have a camel file with the
specification of the experiment I can
push it to github repository then I can
run poly action I can create a link
between local instance of poly action a
project with the remote one and if I'm
after annotations I can upload the
current version of experiments into poly
action registry and then I can run this
gem file ok then outputs if everything
goes well in my poly action output we
can see CSV file with results so this is
only my format of some answers and we
have two pickled files which is model
and model phone transformation you map
we used to scikit-learn so we pickled
the model but if we had tensorflow
it would be saved and another format of
course and the configuration a drama
file inside as something like this so we
have group of experiments I specified
that the concurrency is 20 and then I
have some metrics of parameters so I
wanted to have all possibilities all
permutations of Kimmel's
algorithm of clustering I wanted to have
experiments with ten clusters I want to
have experiments with 20 clusters and
fifty ones and also I can try different
distant metrics between clustering so I
want to cosine metric I went to accrete
and metric and Hamming yeah so Polly
action as we can see we can calculate
that we would have one two three times
one two three nine experiments because
if some of the declarations are a single
entries of course is a one but Polly
action would create nine experiments
with in with each set of parameters and
it schedules that in google out
processing okay also we can have we can
specify the environment resources so if
i don't want to pay much to google i can
request only a half power of CPU or GPU
and i want to specify only a thousand of
megabytes of memory for example and
other specific options and pollux in
config and last stage is build row so I
wanted to use a docker image Python 3.7
to build our container inside Google
will have two processing machine build
steps would be of course some setup
scripts and then I am doing run command
so first of all I we can see that we
have some pipelines of the comments
first of all I can link the killed
packages it is quite legacy code from
the killed version to I have asked ray
called extract data and I have the
Python script so I am calling the run
experiment method from source class and
I am passing all these hyper parameters
from the declarations inside Python file
so it is uncaps elated a bit actually i
pass all the parameters related to the
model training as a parameter of the
code of the class so with that I can
schedule lots of experiments okay and
the final experiment config would be
visible similar okay and also I can lock
parameters like metrics I can lock
metric and parameters at first so each
experiment poly axon handles locks so on
the entrance of the experiment it has
some parameters like hyper parameters
and other stuff and the last within the
training we have to know the accuracy
recall or something so we can lock
metrics with the lock metric with the
lakh metric function and as we can see
poly action also has some panel for
showing the metrics for accuracy
precision and the second one is an
example for time series okay I see that
I'm run of time I also specify some
examples but if we want to ask about
them feel free to eat lunch with me and
ask about some examples of poly action I
was using in that guru so thanks a lot
and if you have any questions please
come to me thanks
any question
thanks for the talk could you tell me
may I use both of these packages without
any kind of cloud providers let's say I
have my own infrastructure
I've have you used DBC before yeah so I
think the DBC has this ability to work
locally yeah but they don't have these
fancy panels yeah I put the poly axon
I'm not sure how many methods of
handling poly action is I think Pollux
and you can use poly action within some
local machine so you have your own
remote server you can set up a poly axon
wrapper and that's all it's okay
about kilt no kilt in version 3 is
focused on s free okay thanks thanks
any question hi thank you for the talk
do you know whether this kilt package is
killed will have a support for Google
storage I actually was having a chat
with outers of kilt for now they said
this they refer the version of kilt to
so privileged previously in the second
version of killed it was possible to
store data rather locally so our local
instance on our local machine and some
other server guilt free is focused on
AWS s3 and what was told is they wanted
to have a support for Google Cloud and
for adjure from Microsoft but not in
this version maybe in the future let's
ask them about in healthier maybe okay
thanks thanks
hi I've got a question about because you
said that you are using Polly axon with
Google clown right and yes you killed it
seems to be like more on as we do use
them together somehow or is it like a
part of yes I used all of these tools
together as these circles I was shown on
the diagram was how I killed healthy
Polly action and you can see as a rather
a legacy configuration but Polly action
uses skilled somehow so if I run
experiment via Polly action Polly action
have has to know where the where the
data is come comes from so we need to
somehow tell Polly action that aggrieved
is a source we have to of course install
quilt python package into docker which
we are running on Polly action and then
if cute and Polly action meets each
other it's it's a good way to make
experiments thanks thanks
any question I don't see thank you
thanks a lot
[Applause]